let's jump into this first story we're
gonna talk about gun control
biden says no amendment in the
constitution
is absolute and calls gun violence a
public health crisis
and embarrassment as he prepares to sign
six executive orders
cracking down on firearms there's two
things i want to highlight as we start
this conversation
he says nothing about i'm about to
recommend in any way
impinges on the second amendment you
mean infringes
yeah he didn't say that word oh boy
these are phony arguments
suggesting that these are second
amendment rights at stake no amendment
to the constitution is absolute biden
declared
and then he points to the famous supreme
court ruling from i think it's 1919 that
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
and that was shank
as part of the first amendment's free
speech clause which is wrong because in
brandenburg v ohio i believe was
1969 they ruled actually you can yell
fire in a crowded theater joe biden has
to know
i'm assuming he knows that or he's a
[ __ ] i'm assuming he knows it because
he has legal experts who actually helped
craft his executive order policies he
wouldn't be saying stupid garbage
unless he's trying to mislead people
because this is what
they do or he hadn't had his nap yet and
he might have been a little slow
that's that's that's fair point
absolutely i would like to point out
impinge is a word
i know that is i was saying he's not
saying infringe
because that's actually what's in the
constitution yeah i see
right right he's getting cheeky the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
but but impinged i guess it works i'm
just saying
shall be impinged he didn't want to get
too close to actually using the language
that would go oh
i see what you're doing check this out
he said from the very beginning you
couldn't own any weapon you wanted to
own that's a lie
and from the very beginning of the
second amendment existed certain people
weren't allowed to have weapons
so the idea is just bizarre to suggest
that some of the things we're
recommending are contrary to the
constitution
so here's what's going to happen you you
get these lies over and over again
the first thing i'm going to say studies
have found liberals on twitter for the
most part only follow liberals whereas
conservatives follow both conservatives
and liberals
it has changed a little bit for the most
for the most part though it is still
true
and the other thing we see is that
liberals get about
about 95 percent of their news from
liberal sources moderates get 60 of
their news
they get about two-thirds from liberal
and one-third from conservative and
conservatives are inverted getting about
two-thirds from conservative
and one-third from liberal news sources
what this means is that people we call
liberals are in bubbles
they don't have any idea what's actually
going on outside that bubble and then
you get the media
telling them lies so now people are
going to hear this over and over and
over again
you you can't yell fire in a crowded
theater see free speeches limits
okay well you're wrong that's that was
overruled in and i think 1969.
then they say you couldn't own any gun
you wanted to usa today
fact checked this and a bunch of
historians were like there actually
weren't really any laws limiting the
right of private cities
private citizens private citizens in the
revolutionary war era from owing from
owning military-grade weapons
cannons artillery grape shot all that
stuff and then when they talk about
yeah well you you a muzzle uh
muzzleloaded rifles muskets
took a minute to reload yes and they had
volley guns since the
since 1339 i think a volley gun is when
they have a bunch of different barrels
all loaded
and you have one trigger pole which
fires all of them off which is fully
automatic
so biden is wrong he is outright denying
our constitutional rights
in order to justify his executive orders
which violates the constitution
so moving moving into this bigger
conversation we'll get about talking
about guns and about second civil war
all that stuff
a lot of people have said you know they
view second civil war or civil war as
like factions marching down the street
i don't think that's what it'll look
like i think it'll be more like
insurgency if it does get to the point
of violence but we've already seen proud
boys in antifa and right wing and left
in groups clash
but more importantly it's a cold civil
war and this is one of the elements of
it
telling you your rights don't exist and
then passing executive orders
that's despotic trump the worst thing
trump did was the bomb stock ban
because that was not now i think the
supreme court i'm sorry there
one court has ruled i think it was what
the ninth district i could be wrong
that bomb stocks are not machine guns so
that may actually get overturned
but they complain all day about donald
trump's executive orders well here's joe
biden
well and here's the thing when you talk
about a a civil war
okay shooting in the streets happened
already all right so we have had that
but what about information warfare which
we are constantly bombarded with what
about the fact that like you said
the constitutional rights are being
trampled upon
in a way that if if the left was
actually trying to spark an insurrection
what would they do differently all right
they're isolating us
on social media and shutting down our
right to speech
they're trying to disarm us they have
declared whiteness
to be a an evil thing so they're
othering
an entire large segment of the
population
and they're they're using police powers
against us they're refusing to let the
police
help people during the riots they
actually had the police called off
what would they do different if they
weren't actually trying to turn this
into a hot war well would you consider
what mao did with the communist
cultural revolution a civil war a
chinese civil war
that probably more on the purge side
from him you know because that was that
was
using police state powers against it i
think we're still empowered enough
as conservatives or people of the right
whatever you consider yourself i mean
i'm a libertarian conservative even
moderates even lighter
i'm not a particularly conservative
person the interesting thing is that i
get labeled conservative for simply
telling the truth
and not being a statist so if you're an
anti-statist
you automatically get lumped on that
side of the political sphere this is the
craziest thing about it
is that this subject matter you discuss
determines whether you're left or right
not your political policies because i've
had
we had we had jack murphy and michael
mauson here and i got into arguments
about
the wealthy and their ability to
influence elections with dumping massive
amounts of money and i said i'm against
it
i don't think these people should have
this much power much more traditionally
left position
those you're you're not going to see
these grifters on social media take
those clips of me screaming like
these billionaires and millionaires are
you know
are manipulating our elections they
don't want to show that because then i'm
not right-wing anymore and they need me
to be
well and the the dividing line is not
right or left as much as it is statist
or libertarian individualist if you
believe
you can best determine what you should
be doing as long as you're not hurting
other people
then you're on my team if you believe
the state or the solons of the woke left
know better than you how to live your
life and what you should do then you're
on the other team
and you're my enemy and i don't mind
saying you're my enemy because they're
trying to
to push us out of polite society they're
trying to criminalize conservatism or
the ideas
that they find offensive and i find that
offensive
right and you but i'll tell you this ian
brings up a good point about
china because uh you know ian asks about
what mao did
you say it's more of a purge and i
thought to myself you know what you're
right maybe it's not a second civil war
because conservatives for the most part
aren't fighting it
well but we need to and that's why i i
wrote the book for one reason and and
the problem with the right is that we we
to oh eagles don't flock you know i'm
not gonna be part of a movement or do
anything
so they can pick us off one by one so
they can do things like let twitter shut
us down like
you guys were looking for my twitter
account tonight guess what you can't
find it
because they grade me out they put a
sensitive filter so you can't even find
me by name
because they don't like what i say i
haven't violated their rules yeah not a
single
one and they they banned uh josie the
right-handed libertarian for literally
no reason
it's a libertarian account you know she
interacts she's a friend of ours
and they just deleted her it's in their
terms of service they can ban anyone for
no reason
and they will it's a social media credit
score and they're doing that they're
how they do it what algorithms they're
using to to actually do it
i don't know but it's obvious they're
doing it because i haven't violated i
haven't gotten a single strike
and yet my you don't even see my face
you know you see grayed out
profile picture when you go to my
twitter feed look the social credit
system is legit
they might not have a legitimate score
or algorithm that calculates it
but we know it's real like you're the
wrong kind of person with the wrong
opinions and then all of a sudden you
start getting banned from different
platforms if you don't break the rules
you start getting suppressed and shadow
banned
and then they ultimately ban you if your
opinions are bad and that's why we got
to stand up that's why the
people who are not status not
totalitarian unwoke
based white pillars whatever we want to
be i don't care
but we got to band together against it
and stand up and say no so how do we
prevent
a purge and a civil war without firing a
shot
the first thing you got to do is stand
up and fight because too many people on
the right have been complacent we were
focused on other things it's one of the
things i talk about in the book
the right thought that if we just focus
on foreign policy and national security
and business and then the the
constitution will keep us safe
they can't take that away can they and
we found out we were wrong
well define fight fight in the
figurative term
and let me give you how about let's do
it but i mean like sorry i
i didn't think you meant literally go
physically fight people just like what
would a person have to do
to be engaged in this this cultural
battle yeah but first let me let's give
the disclaimer so that when people come
after you they don't blame you for my
book
neither tim nor i want a civil war or an
insurrection and this is a no
way be considered to be a call for
anything
like that not a dog whistle or anything
else you losers
now figuratively how we can fight is by
banding together and standing up
and we have to actually change our focus
we never used to do that
did conservatives go to pta meetings you
know did we get involved in state and
local politics
no we didn't think we had to we thought
that the constitution of first amendment
second amendment were sacrosanct
they're not they're they're coming for
us so if they're coming for us
we have to play the same game and like
andrew breitbart said
war these people are evil they are i
look i
i i grew up with this very pragmatic
you know very middle of the road view i
was pretty far left when i was younger
and i always had this this this view
where it's like there's no real good or
evil everyone's to hear of their own
story
and now as i'm older you start to really
see it and experience it it's it's an
interesting thing you hear a lot from
people about
how when they get older they start to
become they start to believe more in a
higher power
more faith-based especially when they
have kids i'm not i'm not getting
religious i'm just saying
man you really start to understand what
evil is once you get older you get
involved in politics you see what these
people do
the the number one example that really
just like
was when i when i heard this one thing
that's when my heart sank and i was like
wow i have been too nice to people it
was when aoc referred to the child
detention centers as
influx facilities with controversial
records
she spends what during the trump
administration
concentration camp over and over and
over again
trump shut down the homestead facility
biden reopened it
an aoc who had called it a concentration
camp
today says influx facility with
controversial record i was like
wow so what is it what are you going to
wear she can wear
black this time is versus the white
outfits you got to have a different
outfit because it's a different
administration understand the simplest
thing which you just outlined
everybody they will say whatever they
have to
because they're just after power they
want power to tell everyone what to do
because they don't believe
people make the decisions that they
believe need to be made
and they think it's a question of good
and evil like you said they think they
are the forces of good
stopping evil from destroying the planet
you know it's not just that you don't
believe in climate change you're killing
the planet
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time